I live in New York City I fled like
Chicago because the day we had our first
interview I got robbed
by black women and it's okay anybody can
be tiffed there she was punching me into
my wallet or even for my son who's in
Chicago yes that exact that afternoon I
went off but the thing is people weren't
on the streets circle around me that I'm
a I'm a racist that was trying to call
the cops on the stiffs
yeah
so people are crazy in Chicago they just
lost Common Sense they're never gonna
defend anybody because of my skin color
I was not having a black skin colorway
and then it was so I mean I charged her
to she was prison and then apparently
there's a huge Revenge crime they come
out they bring the gun to shoot you and
I'm a public person they know where I am
so I had to foolish cover and come to
New York
I go with my son take a Subway and it is
beyond dangerous the first thing that is
Korean women telling me don't go near
the tracks because this people
especially black people just push Asian
people this is New York from Chicago New
York did you think it was safer in New
York
it's not but what shocked me was on
every corner in downtown in New York
they said like drugs in the purple like
a looking like candy
and my son thinks it's a lollipop they
are selling so he just keep asking me to
buy the lollipop for him
so so like the southern border is open
I mean I'm not safe Living in America
it's so funny like I was looking for
security and safety and freedom now I
didn't get the security and safety in
America
so our country is like this much of mass
and we are defending some other people's
security like what about American
Security I'm All American my son is
American and I first I'm like I'm
literally risking my life every day
taking that Subway and we have to take
this opinion nobody can afford to have a
bodyguard and take a like driver take
you around
I think that's why I'm so like password
like what is this
so how long how much longer are you
planning on staying in New York I can't
because of custody of my son I got you
you have to be in the same city yeah
yeah well have you spoken to him about
leaving New York
well his name is always safer than
Chicago at least it's like a little bit
more safer than Chicago so it's a
relative thing
you don't get shot and bullets run
through you as much as Chicago so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign
[Music]